[Music]
hey what's up welcome to cold revenge
the wisecracks podcast where we break
down everything happening in the
cultural zeitgeist I'm Michael and I'm
here with Alec hey Alec how are you hey
I'm great and here with Serbia who has
an electronic chair Serbia how you doing
today hi I'm well thanks how are you I'm
so good I'm so good jealous of the chair
for those who aren't watching or weren't
here earlier in the studio we learned
that Serbia has a chair that magically
rises and falls as she wills so lots to
talk ask Oh sir we can't do demo anyway
quite a bit to talk about this week so
without any further ado does anyone have
any slaps and tramps from the last two
weeks I do then yeah what slaps is
Jared's back and that rules and doing
his job is I don't envy it I'll just
leave it at that and then for what chaps
I'm one episode behind but I think it's
safe to say that I will continue to
watch it but Star Trek Picard is bad and
I hate it and I will watch every single
episode from now until the end of time
but really quick is the Picard thing
isn't he like a he runs a vineyard and
is making wines or am I getting this
wrong yeah he always there was a
reference to that in the original and
the next generation that he had a
vineyard
okay that to me that sounds like a
pleasant show but I haven't watched it
yet so well anything else that's
currently chapping you're behind I think
that's it I think everything is great
and wonderful and there's no how to
complain about ever that's the state of
the world view through my eyes Oh sir be
what's slap image happen so it slaps is
that Pet Shop Boys and New Order are
going on tour I'm very excited so I'm
going to buy tickets for that what chaps
is that I
can't seem to find really warm winter
clothes I'm going I'm traveling abroad
next month and it's going to be super
cold and ever since I had that horrible
reaction to the Hep A vaccine I get
hives whenever I'm really cold so I've
been buying different jackets and things
and nothing seems to be warm enough for
me
I really just recommend layering not
that you asked for recommendations no I
want recommendations that's what I
forgot so if anybody has recommendations
please let me know if anyone has
recommendations please throw them our
way but like what material for the
record like for the layers I've spent
way too much time thing about layering
cuz I'm gonna long hiking trip but uh
what what hikers do is they'll have like
a puffy which is usually like a down
jacket but like a thinner one like not a
very heavy one and then you have a base
layer which you could do a lighter layer
or like a mid weight layer so think
about like a long sleeve usually like
athletic material although you're not
gonna be sweating or maybe you will so
that won't be bad and then kind of like
a hoodie over that and then you put your
puffy and I've been just doing that all
winter in New York and so when it gets
under 30 degrees it's not that
sustainable and I have to pull out my
big wool coat but it's kept me pretty
warm so for the down jacket what Phil do
you recommend because I bought a 550 and
I was really cold at like 60 degrees I
think you just got a layer stuff under
it I don't know I don't know the
specific fills because I have like got a
synthetic thing that is like the anyway
well that's good and I'm glad that this
has now turned into an athletic wear
podcast that's what we've always wanted
it to be so awesome
someone did ask in the chat if there is
something on the Bojack finale coming
and I just want to say yes just so they
know yeah yeah there's a Thomas
Ambrosini one of our writers is pitching
me a thing that we haven't quite figured
out but hopefully when I read it more
thoroughly it's the best idea I've ever
heard me on the the channel in a month
or so yeah or hypothetically a good bad
and brilliant that's completely about
the finale of Bojack oh yeah that was
already filmed yeah
Wow I feel pretty overlooked so what
chaps for me is alec overlooking the
work that I do to talk about things that
haven't been created yet which will be
good I'm sure I'll do mine real quick
what's laps in my world the TV show high
maintenance came back on HBO since we
were last year I think I can confidently
say overall it's my favorite show
I've never lived in New York but I feel
like it gives me this like interesting
view into Alex world so that's great and
the other thing I'll say I'm gonna be
greedy and due to a portrait of a lady
on fire French film was out in limited
release is now on why I really saw it
the other night truly phenomenal movie
anyone who lives near theater this plane
it should go see it just fantastic what
chaps did two quick things
grocery stores went to one the other day
in Albertsons had a really hard time
finding anything that I wanted couldn't
come up with a meal that I wanted to
create an just thought to myself how are
there thousands of things and nothing
that I want found that frustrating and
the other thing is I think my best
friend might be moving to Europe chasing
a woman not chasing like he's gonna do
anything bad like like a love chase but
that's I don't like that cuz you want
your friends around you you don't want
then in Europe finding love so I wish
that all my friends remain unhappy and
near me I feel like I left it on a
bummer note so I apologize oh no shoot I
didn't mean to do that everything's
great love is real and everyone who's
good will find it and everyone on this
podcast is good so let's get into our
topics for this week we have a lot to
get to including a special guest later
in the episode I don't want to spoil it
but please stick around or should we
spoil it spoil
okay it's uh Jamie Loftus is comedian
she's a writer
she joined Mensa for a year and made a
podcast about it and I thought it was
really funny so I was like we got to
interview this person so we did
pre-recorded it but we'll play for you
all and it's it's awesome and it's great
so stick around for that I'm gonna start
things off if it's okay with you all
this week talking about something that I
I find myself thinking about a lot
which is influencer culture but in
particular the influencer culture that
has been created by the TV show The
Bachelor well let me ask this at the
outset our cursor be have either of you
ever watched any of the properties
associated with The Bachelor extended
universe maybe you like 10 years how it
went to the first show first air oh god
I think it's been on for almost 20 years
I think I might have seen parts of the
first season as like a teenager
yeah is that where you learned about
love yes I think everything I know I
learned as a 12 year old well
I and I'm just gonna admit this and
everyone can roast me in the live chat
if you want to deserve it
I've been regularly watching The
Bachelor and their other shows like
bachelor in paradise and the
Bachelorette for I'd say about the last
five or six years and there's this
cultural change that's happened in the
show that I do think is parallel to a
lot of things happening in our culture
in general now when the show first
started out it was kind of a show where
maybe overly idealistic people who
wanted attention would go on TV
attempting to find love and in the early
seasons you can kind of categorize the
contestants into one of those groups
either they stupidly think that going on
TV is a good place to find love or they
just want to be on TV to to hit some
sort of narcissistic pleasure center in
their brain and it was all well and good
early on a few of the couples would get
married a few of the early ones actually
stayed together had kids all that sort
of stuff what's happened in recent years
however is rather than becoming a place
to go get attention or find an
idealistic form of love it's become a
sort of minor league system for online
influencer marketers so you go on this
show these days with no real intention
of finding love of getting into a real
relationship you go to get enough
attention to get a big enough follower
count to then make deals with all of the
brands that make exclusive deals the
people that have been on these shows now
for a few seasons this was kind of
happening in the shadows like we knew it
was taking place and no one would
acknowledge it now however contestants
will sort of try to sabotage each other
in the most recent season a young woman
who was on the show
Makenna got thrown under the bus cuz she
was already workshopping the hashtags
she was going to use on her social media
and she got off to get deals and it's
it's not a thing as well where people
are making a little bit of money off of
this there's a couple that got married
from the show called Tanner and Jade who
have made and I'm not exaggerating
millions of dollars off sponsored
Instagram post um they are legitimate
millionaires because of this and it's
not all social media influencing others
have gone on to start podcast where they
talk about the show that they were on
that has that I've really high paying
sponsors some of them do these events
around the country now or they'll go to
like a convention center people there on
the show will speak and then they'll
sell like branded jewelry and things
like this so it's hit a new level of
cynicism in this so what I wonder is
well and how I think this I guess
touches on our culture as a whole is it
makes me think about how many spaces in
society are just places for wannabe
grifters to get enough attention to
leverage their followings and sponsored
content or their own media brands
because this doesn't just happen on The
Bachelor it happens with like resistance
Twitter and people that that like get
involved in causes like there's all of
these ways now that people can grips and
of course we all know about like fire
festival and Thera notes and all these
large-scale grips but because you all
are not members of bachelor nation which
is what we call ourselves I mean am I
overreacting or are we just seeing a
large-scale cultural shift towards
grifting being the new career path for
attention hungry Millennials
I think grifting is pretty old but it's
definitely it's a new type of grifting
right it's like a new and exciting form
of grifting speaking of grifting I
walked by and saw a salt they opened a
restaurant and the restaurant isn't I
swear it just called hashtag salt Bay
not salt Bay they put the little pound
sign in there the food looked really
good though but sorry sir B I I really
relate to these people because the only
reason why I'm on this podcast is
because I want to be an influencer
Graham I barely have a Twitter so I
don't know how this is gonna work out
for me but we'll see and let me just
interject you to say things to do to
bides through some coin our way and said
he loved the episode Alec and I did
about righteous gemstones on Caban
brilliant so thank you so much dude
abides thank you so well here's a
question has the so in my mind the
people who used to be on reality TV
shows like the people who they could
they recruit people who seem to be the
most mentally unstable that would make
good TV and the people there's like a
selection bias the people who are most
mentally unstable or the person who says
I want to be film in 24 hours a day
while I'm having sex with random people
yeah and not just any Jew millionaire
whatever reality show there's there's
something there but now is it more
mentally stable competent because here's
my thing about grifters they're usually
super smart and I'm not calling these
people dumb I think they know exactly
what they're doing and have just made a
choice and are sticking with it and so
is it is there more self-awareness are
they are they're sort of smarter more
stable more competent people on the
shows now yeah so that you can really
break down the people that come on the
show and to maybe like three categories
that are split amongst thirds you do
have the traditional crazies people that
show up especially on The Bachelor like
first night and a weird outfit get
shit-faced and make a mess of themselves
then in the middle you have this
category of people that present is
relatively normal but but are not
they're clearly in for the grift or
they're already planning their next move
these are the people that like stuff
comes out when social media when the
show airs showing their previous sketchy
behavior and the final third you have
the geniuses the geniuses are the ones
that completely present as earnest
honest people that are here and this is
the code word we use in this community
that are here for the right reasons
that's always the question that gets
asked people was I don't think she's
here for the right reasons but the
people who are quote unquote here for
the right reasons who go further in the
competition because of course the
crazies get let off week weeks one two
three the kind of mid-level
earnest but we can see through it people
get led off what's like weeks four
through seven the people that stick
around the longest
end up having the biggest Griff's
because they then come across as someone
who like was here for the right reasons
and I found love and it didn't work out
but I'm excited to tell you about this
new tee that makes me poop out all my
weight or something so it's it's almost
the people who seem the less obvious in
their grift who are clearly the ones
making the most off of this and it's
sort of the mindset is the longer you
stay in the game
the more money you're going to make at
the end which means in some cases people
this is kind of dark might be having
sexual intercourse with someone they
don't even care about that much because
you got to get to fantasy suite week to
stick around the longest to get to the
end of this [ __ ] maybe I should try out
for The Bachelor yeah it could be fun
you get to stay in a nice mansion at
first and they do some good trips they
went to Cleveland this season in winter
so but then they immediately went to
like like South America and stuff in
Buenos Aires and this kind of reminds me
of the corporate world like I I always
get off like weeks one through three
because I feel like I'm the one who's
always like this culture is whack like
what's going on like this is so weird
I'm the one who's always making noise
the people who know how to play the game
they're the ones that like climb the
ladder and they're the ones that get the
promotions and things so I feel like
there's a lot of parallels between these
like influence or grifters and people
who do really well in the workplace for
my experience and I mean good for them
if they figure this out and they can
make money by being an influencer that's
good I think there's also another
interesting expansion in any reality
show not just the competition shows I
feel like the personalities are turning
into influencers or and maybe the
slightly different have their own
products that they peddle as influencers
and so some friends of mine really like
that show about the Duggar family and
there's like a million of them and they
all have like podcasts yeah yeah and you
know they have sponsorships and are
selling stuff or the little people big
world family I remember there was one
son in particular who stopped being on
the tea
show and in this long Instagram tirade
talked about how everything was fake and
quoted noam chomsky which is awesome for
you I think so or even I've been
following hikers on like even hikers who
are doing the Pacific Crest Trail like
that wild movie whatever are now doing
podcasts where they're talking about
their favorite products and I think some
of its in earnest like oh here's the
backpack that I used and you should use
it too but I also think some of it is
give me that cash money from this $300
sleeping bag yeah but in case I feel
like gross like like a hiker promoting a
backpack whatever like you're probably
not making millions off that the
backpack you're promoting is probably
fine whatever
I get worried about some of the more
odious stuff where you know there was a
whole thing that happened and there was
an article like this I think in new york
times about some of the resistance
grifters like people that are to these
twitter accounts after the 2016 election
who many of them turned out to be not
who they said they were who had
conflicting political beliefs to that
which they said some were outright like
really bad people who created big
social-media followings that they cashed
in on and so that really worries me I do
wonder if either of y'all have thoughts
on this like how does the bottom fall
out on this well what is the market
collapse scenario of the influencer
economy because it's bound to happen I
think there was a little bit of it but I
don't think like I think a bubble burst
a few years ago in that influencers were
kind of new and buzzy and I was working
at some jobs where like marketing was
involved and the people were just throw
money at influencers saying hock my
product post about me on Instagram but a
lot of it doesn't actually work
sometimes like when Kim Kardashian
decides to sell something she says she's
pushing like it's probably well worth
the investment but a lot of people are
just grifting their way to you know free
hotel stays and free drinks and free
products and stuff like that and so I
think not all the money dried up but I
think people started to be much more
cautious so in a way I think it has but
then again I think there's sort of like
the creme de la creme of like I was on
The Bachelor those are the people still
cashing in on
but yeah I don't know I don't think the
bottom will fall out on that I think it
will just slowly overtake our lives
where every single person has some side
hustle of selling things on Instagram
and that that's what really worries me
surbhi thoughts on this I agree I don't
think that I see this ever going away I
do think that consumers will be savvy
err though and maybe it'll be like a
fatigue like influencer fatigue where
people will just be like oh okay she's
just talking about this makeup for an
because she has a sponsorship so maybe
that's what will happen people will just
get tired of it
but I don't see brands not doing it
especially if they're able to find
somebody who has like a million
followers or something they all still
pump money into that I have a really
inspiring story I hope I didn't mention
this before but without fail is an
interview show they interviewed the
first like makeup influencer who
essentially left she created YouTube
channel with makeup tutorials got very
very famous and very very rich and quit
because she said that she doesn't like
going to these parties with cool people
she'd rather stay home with her cat and
I really respect doctors that's nice
there's a good Thundercat song if anyone
listens to Thundercat about how he just
wants to hang out with his cat and he
put out a new song recently that
reference is having cat hair on his cool
clothes a question for you all but first
a statement for myself why I do hope
that the bottom falls out a little bit
because my hope for the bachelor to get
back to the bachelor is that eventually
the bottom falls out on this bachelor
economy people realize it's no longer a
viable career and they get back on the
show for the right reasons they go on
the show because they want to find love
and in our alienated and fractured
society the best chance they have is to
live in a house with a bunch of
strangers have two drinks an hour
because that's the maximum amount of
drinks are allowed to have in an hour an
hour on that show and and meet a great
pilot from outside Los Angeles or a
dental hygienist from Milwaukee or a
mortuary worker from the San Fernando
Valley that's what I want to see wait
and I hope it gets out there I have a
sorry last question do we think you know
how
people's jobs will become obsolete at
some point and then what do we do with
all these truck drivers now that we
robots have taken or that hasn't
happened yet but you know coal miners
industry it always happens even football
players like the problem with football
players is they join the NFL they make a
lot of money for a very specific amount
of time and they have no money and it's
like really rough for them and a lot of
them have traumatic brain injuries do we
think that's gonna happen with the class
of influencers is that there will be a
host of people with no job skills and
when that all kind of evaporates or when
they get too old to be cool and selling
things they're just going to be
thousands and thousands of people who
are unemployable that we have to figure
out what to do with as a society I
actively think about this because some
of these people in the Batchelor
universe they like leave jobs there's
people who have left jobs as lawyers who
some of whom were doing like legit law
public defense work and they leave those
careers imagine how much time and money
goes into becoming a lawyer and you
leave that career to like Huck lipstick
or shoes I find that insane and and I
think you're right I think there is
going to be a big class of people with
no marketable skills because of this and
it really worries me now now to wrap up
with this I do have a question and we'll
start with surbhi if you were an
influencer what would you what do you
think your brand would be what sort of
stuff are you Hawking what products are
we seeing on your feet it would be
things that I use or like things that I
would want things that I think are great
like travel stuff like oh this suitcase
or like his airline is really nice it
wouldn't be like I don't wear a lot of
makeup so it wouldn't be anything like
that unless it was like makeup that I
used so it would I would try to be as
authentic as possible which I like the
modern millennial on the go yeah your
travel based lifestyle will be here to
influence us all and help us plan our
next hashtag getaway yeah so if you have
a hashtag for me let me know okay great
so make a hashtag for servi if anyone
has on the chat that'd be great
Alec what what is your post bachelor
brand going to be
books I'm sure that's not a viable
strategy but if people would pay me to
recommend books that would be really
cool I already know no way that's what I
do is I just say I read this cool book
and I put a I wrote about it yeah I see
you an image right now have you like on
a couch kind of like covered in books is
like a bit like someone covered in sand
on the beach with like your cat kind of
on the thing next to you and then that's
that's your routing that's really good I
like that so what about you what what
are you what are you Hawking
oh man probably just fast fast casual
cuisine never anything too nice but for
example like I found out that Chipotle
has a new queso blanco they're releasing
so I'm probably doing post where I'm
like going around town with queso blanco
mixing it with different things
introducing people to their new queso
blanco and and other chains like that
highest end I could see myself going is
maybe like a sweet green but any any
place we're out we're in the 20s with
tax it's not a part of my brain where
words between between $8 and $19 I got
you I thought that it would be that
wicking clothing oh never mind you're
totally right sweat life my entire brand
would be products and goods to help the
modern sweaty man survive in the urban
environment thank you so much for
correcting me sir B screw fast casual
food well thanks for letting me indulge
my bachelor conversation thanks for
everyone who's listening who let me do
that I know it's a little bit off-brand
sir B what do you have for us today so I
was talking to a friend of mine at work
and she was telling me that she knows of
somebody who's donating her kidney and I
unfortunately don't know this person so
I can't pepper her with questions and
invade her privacy
so I turned to the Internet to learn
more and I learned that in the u.s.
there are over 100,000 people on the
kidney transplant waiting list and the
wait could last between five to ten
years and only twenty-two thousand
donations are performed in the US every
year
and while ninety-five percent of you
adults support organ donation only 58%
are signed up as donors so one reason
why so few kidneys are available is that
there was this law that was passed in
1984 that said pain for organs is
illegal and the BBC recently looked at
kidney donations and asked the question
should we pay kidney donors so the
people who say no believe that if we
start paying people for kidney donations
individuals will flood the donation list
wanting the financial incentives but
they won't fully understand what they're
getting themselves into some of the
long-term effects of kidney donation are
nerve damage pain reduced kidney
function high blood pressure and the
National Kidney Foundation they're a big
influencer in the field they oppose
paying for kidneys because they say that
any attempt to assign a monetary value
to the human body risks devaluating the
very human life we seek to save which I
don't know that I agree with but let's
move on to the people who say yes we
should pay for kidneys so they combat
these hesitations by saying that we can
put in safeguards like built-in waiting
periods to educate people about the
effects we can have delayed compensation
and payment doesn't have to be cash it
could take the form of tax credits
school vouchers or other long-term
government benefits the other thing they
say is that half a million Americans are
on dialysis so if you don't get a kidney
and now you're on the waiting period the
other option is to do kidney dialysis
and each patient costs $100,000 a year
and according to one estimate if the US
government offered $45,000 for every
donated kidney there would be a net gain
of 46 billion dollars so what do you
think
we pay for kidney donors I don't really
see a downside to it and I'm very
curious if I'm missing something it
makes me very very I'm sensitive to I
think both sides of the argument so I
think the best way to put is that makes
me very very nervous and I think one way
too I read the article you're talking
about and I don't think it did the best
job of explaining like what the possible
downside is and I think plainly it is
that you're going to have a class of
people who are selling organs and kind
of doing damage to their body because
they're in financial issues like imagine
being a mother who can't pay her bills
and like well should I better sell a
kidney and we could talk about the
protections and stuff like that in a
second
but I think philosophically you know the
one conceptions that we should pay
people is that you know you have to like
a party agreeing to a thing there's a
consensual exchange of services if you
will or you know goods and services but
the other is I was brushing up on Isaiah
Berlin and maybe he's not the best
person to frame this plays a phosphor I
came up with this idea of positive or
negative Liberty and I think this is
interesting way to think about kidneys
that kind of complicates the the notion
that you can just willingly sell your
kidney and it's like end of the day like
why would you stop that and he's talking
specifically about smoking and let me
just get this out of the way
gives us example you're driving on a
road you take a right turn because
there's nothing blocking you it's sweet
you take a left turn nothing blocking
you there you get the fork you go
whatever way you want and that is in the
absence of restrictions to your freedom
right nobody is choosing how or where
you can go right and so that's like a
predominant way we think about freedom
but then he says what if you're at the
fork and you take a left-hand turn
because you have a tobacco craving I
need to go pick up cigarettes and what
he argues is there's this other kind of
freedom that is more about our full
sense of agency and his argument is you
know for the addicted smoker they are
not truly like in control of themselves
and now I'm not claiming people selling
kidneys to be addicted to cigarettes or
anything like that but I think when you
think about being in control of your
action
there are so many external factors and
one of them is just like financial
duress for instance you know they're
gonna foreclose on your house and so
you're gonna do things and not just with
selling kidneys but like lots of
decisions people make are done out of
this and not necessarily their own they
wouldn't have made that decision
otherwise and so I think it always runs
the danger of that and I think with
things like this you get and not just
organ donation there's a lot of things
where it just seems like poor people are
subsidizing the rich with you know labor
and body parts and stuff like that
and so that worries me on the other end
you know donate your kidney maybe get
paid for it I there was also discussion
of non financial rewards that most
people were cool with and I'd be totally
fine with if you donate your kidney
we're gonna send you to like the coolest
resort in Tahiti you're gonna have a
great time two weeks off that doesn't
feel like some sort of like exploitation
there yeah I mean I I don't want to
retread the wonderful ground that Alec
just shredded here so eloquently but
yeah I worry I would worry about like a
black mirror type dystopian situation
where the poor become the sites for the
organ harvesting of the rich and I think
that if we lived in a society where
people didn't have like crushing debts
and financial needs and they were able
to make a decision on the basis of being
okay sure
I think that'd be great what would
tariff what terrifies me about this idea
is yeah people in desperate situations
who might think like do I foreclosed on
my house or donate my kidney or another
organ do I default on student loan
payments or do I do that and that's
really what would make me nervous about
that the other thing as well is whenever
we mix profit into things like the
ability to continue to healthily live I
get nervous and you know what what
example do we have of a regulated
industry like this where things don't go
relatively poor
so so there's that on the flip side I
wonder if you could do like either the
trip thing I like but maybe there's a
way you do like a tipping system where
when you get into like you know I give
you a kidney and I know that you might
be able to tip you might tip you might
not depends another kidney work so maybe
there's that where it's not required for
that or something like tax credits or
tuition credits at a local university
something like that and I guess the
other thing and and I imagine survey you
know something about this I mean is it
better to put effort into something like
that right now we're to try to continue
to accelerate research into you know
cloned in stem cell-based body parts so
we can just make kidneys so then we
don't have to worry about people say oh
the I freaked you out oh well just like
the idea of growing organs has always
like really um I don't know it's like my
mind refuses to accept it for some
reason because it just feels so sci-fi
mm-hmm um so I when I first had this I
liked idea of doing this for this week I
did my first concern was about the
inequality and will people from low SES
backgrounds be exploited and then I read
about these safeguards like non-cash
options and then I started to think like
oh well my concern was the same as the
the concerns that you brought like are
you going to just sell a kidney because
you need to pay for food and stuff and I
didn't like that but then I was like
well what if you get tax credits or I
like Michael said what if you get
tuition reimbursement or what if
somebody knocks off like loans or what
if you get a trip or something like that
like if it's not cash then does it
change your perspective at all because
it did change mine I think some of those
sound better
so when you say tuition discounts or
something I think that brings up the
same concern of I can't afford college I
need to go to college to have a life and
so I'm going to do that out of
desperation I don't and possibly with
tax credits and you know even where the
argument
is deferred payment again I think it
falls into it but I think when it comes
into something purely like luxury like a
dream or maybe like I don't know a free
iPhone or something like that but to the
Michaels point about what if we just
start growing kidneys I think this
happens in a lot of different areas and
I just remembered one which is an egg
donation so a similar thing happens in
that I'm you can sell your eggs and what
happens is you get like a for drug
hormones that you know make you produce
a bunch and they harvest them whatever
and oftentimes the people out of
financial desperation you need to sell
them and the consumers are like more
wealthy people and there's all sorts of
problems in ethics there's all sorts of
ethics problems going on because the
drugs that they're giving to people to
make them produce more eggs have a lot
of possible risk associated with them
that they're not always forthcoming and
disclosing to the people who are
donating them or the people didn't know
about it was never explained didn't
understand and all these varieties of
things so I think you know the kidney
thing is just one specific example but I
think he could take pretty any you know
sperm I mean sperm donation seems free
harmless but you know I'm saying yeah I
saw an episode of what's it called the
singing competition show American Idol
where a contestant was the product of a
sperm donation and she met her sperm
donation dad and he had over like 27
kids and all the sperm donation kids
like met each other and got together it
was wild I'm sorry that that's
tangential not really no but yeah I
think the two things I think about here
is and I agree with everything's being
said the motivation thing freaks me out
because I am someone who and this isn't
really a bit his I walk around a city a
lot I almost get hit by cars sometimes
la actually has one of the worst track
records for a pedestrian deaths because
of cars but sometimes I think if I get
hit just a little bit maybe shatter a
tibia or something I spent some time in
the hospital whatever but I sue that
person and pay off all my debt and I
truly sometimes think like would it be
worth a few days of crushing pain months
of rehab and whatever to live a
debt-free life
and anything like this worries me
because of those mixed motivations the
other thing I think about is and this is
maybe a more meta question is what the
limits are of the links we will go to to
continue to perpetuate a life that will
definitely end no matter what and this
is a bigger question about kind of
medical ethics and how we conceive of
these things but like it which at which
point do we do do we ever get to a point
where people are just like if they have
the means are just like buying organs
getting blood boys to keep themselves
going all of the sort of stuff on this
infinite quest to live forever and at
what point do we accept this this whole
game we're playing
you know the buzzer is gonna go at some
point for all of us let's enjoy it while
we're here and not go too crazy trying
to indefinitely perpetuate it sorry if
that was a bummer there's an anecdote
but my partner's a researcher goes to
conferences about stem cells and things
like that and apparently always the
weirdest people or the life extension
people who's like whole goal is to
figure out how we can make humans live
forever why like I can't if I have the
option to live forever I don't think I
would take it because yeah what if your
loved ones don't do it and then you're
alone that would make me so sad or I
don't want to spoil anything but like
that yeah if you if one hasn't watched
the final season of the good place I
think this this is the sort of question
they attempt to handle and it's very
interesting yeah yeah exactly that's
exactly what I was thinking of like if
if that was an option to you totally
forever would you want that I don't
think I would how do you want to live
forever no but it'd be cool to look for
a really long time and get to decide
alright I'm a thousand years old or
maybe like I just want the choice to be
like alright I'm 150 visit or maybe I
keep going to him 600 or a thousand or
five thousand but not forever you really
would rather live pain-free like to live
like a like fulfilling life without any
pain yeah a good 75 then
up and down painful 150 well that's what
I'm saying like give me the the choice
right like I you know if I'm imagining
150 I'd be like pretty spry for whatever
reason I don't know but if I wasn't I'd
be like 100 and I'm done Wow so feel
free to let us know how long you want to
live and if you want to sell me your
kidney yeah if you want to sell Serbia
kidney
she's gonna have a venmo link and she
also accepts Bitcoin donate your organs
sign up on the registry or uncomfortable
giving the government your information I
will take your information and I will
accept your Doulton your organs will you
be do the harvesting as well if they
want for an extra fee I'm serving any
final thoughts on this before we move on
no no thank you both awesome so now
we're moving from a shallow people to
great people donating organs to the
anthropological study of geniuses Alec
do you want to set up our interview with
Jamie Loftus about her podcast my year
in Mensa yep
so my year in Mensa is a podcast where
Jamie Loftus who is a comedian and
writer
she says she's successfully tested into
the organisation she wrote about it
joined the largest sort of unofficial
Facebook group of Mensa and that was
sort of a sociological experiment of
it's in an in and of itself it was
interesting to me because at least
online the Mensa conversations weren't
the sort of civil high-minded
conversations you might associate with
people who claim to be very smart but
I'll have a very seating a lot of
seething hatred usually directed at
Jamie because she wrote about them and
kind of poked fun at them she became the
first or second most blocked member on
that Facebook group and then being a
reasonable person said I'm gonna go to
their annual conference and meet all
these people who hate me in person
and they made this podcast about it and
it was really good we'll post the
unedited version on wise cast there's a
lot of Jamie long conversation about her
shoplifting it was great here it is I
think i'ma have to wait it's not hey
everyone we're here with Jamie Loftus
who is a comedian
she has a great podcast called my year
and Mensa we're here today to talk about
Mensa because I listen to podcast and
read her article and thought it was so
amazing that I just want to share it all
with you but specifically the greatest
headline that I've read and at least
this week Jamie was you wrote it it's
called quote good news they let dumb
[ __ ] into Mensa
[Laughter]
pretty good yeah they timeline like ruin
my life for a little while but I still
think it's a pretty good headline ya
know it was just good there was like you
do kind of get even if you're like oh I
think this is silly
there's still kind of that little ego
validation that comes from it that
you're like oh I don't want this to I
wish that I felt nothing but I feel so
you did you feel drunk with power or
like an imposter is like imposter or
both
I did I did shoplift that day that I got
I was like at a forever 21 and I just
kind of I did that thing that you do in
high school you were like I'm just gonna
leave wearing these pants pants what was
it a full-on pair of pants that were
shoplifted when you were drunk with
power for being a newly minted James I
stole their like I mean I felt first of
all I'm like okay stealing from big
companies is allowed yes also they were
like $10 pants they weren't there didn't
lose even a good pair like I think
because I was in the dressing room when
I got the email yeah and then I was like
I think I'm just gonna leave so that was
I think that was my good drunk with
power moment I was excited just just to
step back a little bit Mensa is an
organization that you joined like affirm
your smartness yeah but you you joined
not by taking and IQ is it some more
don't IQ test that you have to take yeah
it's so I took it on like on an
assignment for a website I was writing
for that was just I was just supposed to
write about the experience of taking the
test cuz there is like you can do it two
ways of like if you tested really high
on IQ test when you were younger you can
submit those and then if it's I think
like above a certain number you
automatically get it
but you can also test in with a specific
Mensa test it takes like 2 hours and you
can only take it on like Sundays at 8
a.m. in Pasadena like it was a whole
thing and so I took that test that it
kind of I mean it felt very similar to
like most standardized tests that you
would have growing up it was like
pattern identification and like just
doing a lot of easy math really quickly
there was some that there was definitely
one I wish I'd like remembered it better
but there was one that was kind of pop
culture or just like how many cultural
figures can you identify and what their
profession was but there was stuff like
that too so it was kind of like yeah it
felt like similar not like to the SATs
or like standardized test you take as a
teenager well here's a question do you
consider your like have you historically
considered yourself like a smart person
have you identified that way previously
I think that I like I don't know that's
a very complicated question that I was
trying to figure out in making this
podcast of like I was trying to do some
research on like well what are these
tests for and if you do well on them
what does that even really mean about
you because I like after getting in it
was very clear that it didn't mean
you're a genius
just based on some of the behaviors that
were displayed I'm like okay so this
doesn't mean that you're a genius but
like what does it mean and I think I
mean I had always done like well on
standardized tests but there's a lot of
like really brilliant people who don't
do well in assess and don't test well
and that's like a discussion that's been
going on forever as well I don't know I
think that it just means that I test
well and yeah I don't know I I did those
like those like gifted programs growing
up that I think in retrospect we're not
very good for me and kind of stunted me
socially in a lot of ways and I think
even in my hometown because my mom
teaches in the public school system that
I grew up in they're kind of doing away
with those because it is like you know
like it
and whatever be learning and more
advanced stuff in your kid but if you're
just completely sectioned off from other
people it's not healthy for you and it
like you know I think best case you're
just maybe a little socially awkward
when you are released into the general
public and at worst you're just like
being told you're better than other
people your whole life and that doesn't
really serve as anybody and so Mensa
just felt like the most extreme example
of that
yeah and then it's also like with with
that group you have to be confident
enough in yourself to pay people to tell
you that you're I mean I guess
confidence maybe isn't even the word but
you have to be able to like throw down
whatever 60 70 bucks to be like I will
do well on this test so it's a very like
particular subset of a subset of a
person that will take this test yeah I
thought that was something really
interesting you got that because and
we've sort of talked about this on the
show before but it's like bad tell kids
there's like it's good to tell kids like
oh you studied hard for this test and
you did well and good for you but it's
like bad to be like you're smart and
you're smarter than everyone else and so
I think Mensa is maybe something I've
always liked as an adult kind of
recoiled out because I'm like who the
[ __ ] would join an organization to tell
the rest of the world they're smart and
this is someone who joined the [ __ ]
debate team which is functionally the
same thing except you have to compete
but the thing about debate and just to
defend it for a second you joined
thinking you're the smartest person in
the world and then you get your ass
kicked by literally everyone you're like
well I'm dumb as [ __ ] and really that
was like a good moment for me but so
there's that one side and I want to like
joke and laugh at Mynt Saban the other
side and you really get at this is like
you have a lot of like people who maybe
don't connect with the rest of the world
that well and it's like a place for them
to connect with other people like them
which is like I'm not gonna call that
group as a whole like wholesome but like
that's the wholesome thing about it if
you want to talk about that a little bit
yeah I think that there that was stuff
that I was definitely not thinking about
and sort of I guess ended up making
forcing me to check myself a number of
times throughout the process of like yes
I was receiving a lot of harassment and
it was like frustrating and I couldn't
figure out how to make it stop or switch
the conversation to something that was
productive because it was online so of
course it wasn't going to be but then
like I mean I didn't grow up in a way
that I felt isolated from I mean I
always had someone to talk to and so
yeah I meant like a number of people
just through doing this project that
didn't feel like they had people that
they could talk to you about things they
were interested in and that's like the
good thing about online communities as
you can find those people and Mensah I
think was kind of a shortcut for some
people to do that I also met people who
had joined Mensa because they didn't
have access to higher education and it
was a good thing to have on a job resume
to be like hey I'm really smart and
really competent even though I couldn't
afford a college degree like you know
give me a chance and that was also
something that I never in a million
years would have considered and then
there's people who just joined because
they want to feel better than other
people so hit there's kind of like a
spectrum vulva of reasons to join some
of which are very wholesome or practical
or whatever it is that wasn't stuff I
had considered and so it was I mean yeah
it was good I wish that it didn't you
know I wish people didn't maybe yell at
me so much but but what I ended up
getting like a perspective on it that I
wasn't expecting to I want to talk about
the the yeah so what happened is you
wrote an article joined that the
firehouse is like the the face the
unmoderated Facebook group that like is
the most active Facebook group yeah and
on one sense there was this idea that
you would essentially me as an outsider
like made fun of us how dare you
but essentially like in the Facebook you
were being like dog piled on just like
everyone was [ __ ] on you harassing
you calling you all sorts of like
horrible names there are even some
things like they criticized you for that
I think you're all like you outed a
threat on the Facebook group called the
blue thread which you talked about yeah
we were like I shouldn't make fun of
people who want to consensually share
their boobs like that's cool I shouldn't
I shouldn't have added that to the world
but so everyone's like harassed but
there's a constant refrain that you talk
about in the podcast where some of the
Mensa members are
you just gotta meet him in person it's
it's it's so much better like people are
monsters on the internet but they're
actually nice in person experience that
was kind of unlike anything I'd ever
experienced I still I don't know I still
don't know where I fall on that because
it was for the most part I the most part
I found it to be untrue but I but true
in some ways where some people were like
oh we're really different in person but
that doesn't that they would be too
nervous to talk to me in person so
Michael that that doesn't really feel
like a big enough deviation from like
you know like swinging your dick around
on a private message board and then
being too afraid to say anything to me
in person that's not as big a difference
as you would think it is and but then
there were other other people that I
don't know I mean it was just there were
some examples of people being too nice
to me in person after saying really vile
stuff to me online that felt like such a
big like difference that it felt like
performative well I found that
interesting in the podcast I think yeah
I know you used like fake names was it
key yeah yeah I'm not really surprising
when you introduced this this person in
the story that is the podcast who was
pretty vile to you at an extreme way
online who then I think what by night
too was claiming that you were best
friends yeah really shocking to hear
that yeah that I still just like what
was going on yeah I mean and not that
portion of it felt kind of performative
but then we actually did end up having a
discussion that felt I mean productive
and frustrating and all those other
things that was like oh this is the
conversation I wanted to have the whole
time but it took so I mean that
conversation was there's a zero percent
chance that was ever gonna happen online
in a way that made me check myself again
to where it's just weird when you're
being dog piled on like that like the
things about yourself that other people
will take completely out of context and
pass it off as the truth yeah and you
can almost track like oh I guess I can
see why they might make that assumption
on me based on this context list like
they were going into my facebook account
which I haven't updated since college
because I just haven't really I just
used it to keep in touch with
and keep the people yeah so so it's like
the job that's listed for me is not my
current job and they would find that
information be like why should we trust
this girl she works at like bruger's
bagels like she doesn't know jack [ __ ]
about any and and and stuff like that
and so you're like oh I guess I guess
you know I could have been working at
burgers bagels for the last six years I
haven't been but that is like somehow a
strike against me yeah it is used in
this group or I don't know and then
there's just the people that are like
you you know you suck dick to get work
which is just kind of you know I'm
creative yeah you are in so many
situations that would have paralyzed
people with fear or discomfort and
you're so resilient how did you build
that strength and that resiliency to
process and overcome that situation um I
don't I've that's very nice of you to
say I hmm
I think that there were moments that
it's that's kind of the tricky part of
podcasts where I don't think that in in
the moment I came off as like wow look
at this resilient spirit she's not you
know yet because I was like a wreck as
it was happening I think that some
points I'm like naturally kind of shy in
situations with like complete and total
strangers that so I think in some
moments I probably came off to them as
very nervous and sometimes a little bit
scared depending on what the situation
was but I don't know I mean I think that
I have like past experience and just
like dumb comedy stuff I've done where
it's like the point is to put yourself
in a place of discomfort and if I'm able
to like keep that in mind and be like
okay this feels like garbage but if it
didn't feel like garbage I would be
doing it wrong or something like
something like real keeping major right
yeah just like staying locked in that
mindset like if this felt good then I
I'm not doing something right like it it
was I went into it knowing it was going
to be very uncomfortable I didn't
realize how uncomfortable
and then I think yeah it was just the
only thing I was concerned about was
like physical safety yeah which
fortunately ended up being okay I don't
know yeah I I'd has this experience
impacted the way you share things online
or your interactions with strangers uh
yeah I mean I guess it kind of makes me
think twice of how I present myself
it makes me think a little harder about
when you do get a pile-on I think it is
I don't know I mean I have like
differing opinions from like my own
peers about how to best handle this of
like a lot of people are like well if
someone talks [ __ ] to you life is too
short block them there's no space for
that and I understand that but that's
just not the way that I choose to
approach it and I think that like most
people are within to to interactions of
forming some sort of empathy because
mostly it's like if people are giving
you [ __ ] for a reason that isn't you've
done something horrible it's that
they're whatever they're lashing out and
it's like if you respond they will first
of all be completely shocked and I don't
know I've had but I also have like a
history of like responding to mean
comments and then ending up like forging
strange friendships through that so I'm
probably that it's probably not healthy
but it's it makes me feel better than
just blocking someone it's a brave
strategy yeah I mean I'm sure it'll kill
me someday but well we we hope not
hopefully no one's watching this video a
year from now being like wow she knew
[Laughter]
I think that's about all the time we
have Jamie thank you so much where can
people find you on the Internet where
can they find your podcast what's your
address
where can they find you your one
scariest thing about being a comedian is
you're just constantly advertising where
you'll be and at what time it doesn't
feel safe you could find me online on
Twitter at Jamie Loftus help and on
Instagram at Jamie Christ Superstar and
then the name of the podcast is my year
in Mensa and you can find it pretty much
anywhere you listen to podcasts awesome
yeah subscribe with five star reviews
nice comments although all the stuff
it's really great when we very much
recommend that everyone check it out
thank you a parting question are you
gonna put Mensa on your resume from now
on never never never never no never I I
wash my hands of it but you know I well
I will not be as judgy to anyone else
that does now so what's Mars yeah yeah
thank you so much for having me this is
so much fun yeah thank you so much Jamie
yeah Wow yeah our interview with the
wonderful Jamie Loftus yeah and I just
want to in the chat earlier before the
segment people were establishing who had
the better beard I'm sorry that you lost
Michael I don't want to be a part of the
guy mine isn't good right now it's kind
of I'm in a weird state so you
definitely it's not oh it's a coffee
beer anyone and let me just say for
anyone that enjoyed hearing Jamie talk
about that very accomplished very funny
and very weird in a good way a comedian
so if anyone enjoyed that google her
look her up she tours a lot she has a
really great one-person show called boss
whom is a girl she's been running
recently so check her out if you can she
has a great video on the internet she
did with super deluxe where she gets
leech therapy and leeches are put all
over her it's horrifying
but kind of funny yes and now actually
just to spoil it we're gonna be doing
that for Serbia she's gonna get leeches
on her face during the next podcast and
we'll see how it goes so come back in
but I think you can a patron it's only
available to hate for patrons only
you'll get to watch their feet
therapy that's a part of her brand
hashtag leech life so that's all we have
this has been a great show I think we
can say that we've offered he got
mailbag though oh we do
I thought we didn't we do this is what I
will also say if you want to send us
mail electronic mail mm-hmm coal turbine
jet wisecrack Co we check it and we'll
read your well we might read your thing
but also if you want to call us the
number is Oh God oh I thought you're
gonna say it yeah two one three five
three four eight eight zero seven if you
want to call us leave a voicemail we'd
love to hear your voice two one three
five three four eight eight zero seven
please give us a call all right just a
couple quick emails today we don't have
any voicemails to play for you first one
is from Arthur says hey wisecrack love
the podcast hope everyone's orifices are
okay I appreciate the concern the
loneliness topic I related to oh and had
opinions about as well you guys talked
about socializing more but I think
sometimes it can depend on a person over
the last few years I haven't been in the
best state of mind and by the end of
last year I deleted almost all my
contacts when she ended up being a
pretty good to say decision because I'm
feeling really better now to Survey's
point about private matters I now only
have two friends both of whom are older
than me and tell them about my private
matters and that's working well when I
was at my worst last year I started
watching JoJo's Bizarre Adventure and
I've become so invested that I started
reading them the manga and joined the
fandom too so the actions of watching
reading helped me feel less lonely and
joining the fandom made me feel
connected to other people as always love
all the stuff y'all do and I'm waiting
for the next episode nice that's a great
reminder that not everybody needs to
socialize in the same way and that there
are different outlets to not feel so
lonely so thank you for reminding us
about that the next email from Lucas hi
guys you know the drill a longtime
listener first-time writer welcome I am
writing in about the loneliness segment
recently I had a friend come visit me in
the UK from abroad to study being in the
sixth form that is late high school I
guess the English equivalent I'm
studying hard for finals and I haven't
been
able to hang out with her much for the
month she's been here not having many
other friends here she began to get
lonely so I recommended she try read it
there are subs for other cities and
countries but I've used and recommended
our London social club it's a sub where
people post meetups in the city or ideas
for things they'd like to do but don't
have time don't have people to go with
contrary to popular belief the meetups
are actually full of people of all ages
and surprisingly few neckbeards so it's
been great for me and worked but great
for her so I definitely recommend it
thanks and love everything you guys do
there's one of these for New York City I
subscribe to it but I've never ever gone
to a thing and I should do that that's
good to hear I think I've been hesitant
about stuff like that because I assume
it's gonna be a trap and I'm gonna get
murdered so it's good to hear that it's
just like cool like-minded people of all
ages well you might be able to get
trapped and murdered but that's all we
have awesome again if you want to write
US culture binge at wisecrack dot co
I love to hear from you send us emails
well great so that's all we have so
serbia we'll start with you where can
our listeners slash viewers find you if
they need more sir be content in their
lives suri patel 22 on twitter and i
will create an Instagram so that I can
be an influencer oh yes so get those
hashtags ready please send them in for
next week Alec where can the hungry
people find you I'm on Twitter at
wisecrack Alec that's a le see it's not
Alex don't try typing that his name is
not Alex great I am Michael Oh burns on
Twitter and I'm just gonna do a quick
plug if you haven't checked it out yet
we have a new show called the good the
bad in the brilliant we've had some
great people on Alex been on it Helen's
been on it Tommy's been on it
Jared is on an upcoming episode and we
also recently filmed one with Sam Brown
of the sketch group white as kids you
know so if you haven't had a chance to
check out good bad billion yet please
check it out and let us know what you'd
like to see but that's all for culture
binge we'll be back in two weeks
remember two weeks and we will see you
then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]